today's topic
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm emily he's a stranger i'm kenny
obviously
yes yes
oh my gosh lick two mystery items
blindfolded
should i do it yeah oh god
[Music]
like squint or an octopus
what is sniffing me
oh my god
you know what i do appreciate they just
gave him the hamster but he chose where
she got to kill him yeah
yeah and then but guess he's boss
jesse's boss man
you know she won't know this until she
watches the video better
yes all right well what what the [ __ ] is
this
oh technically guys it's not a hamster
it's a chinchilla
got it here hey man i respect kenny can
you do this thing let's keep watching
you have to drink that one
[Music]
are you drunk already okay
okay but i will get you so
[Music]
oh i did get it call an x and say
you still love them yes i'll do it i
feel like an [ __ ] doing this
you should hello
hello i just want to let you know that i
still love you
yeah i'm totally serious i mean we can
talk more about later i guess i'll call
you back
why you're not trying to do this one day
oh talk dirty to your opponent it must
be really dirty
it would be so hard and then like off
the corner is gonna be someone and
they're going to come over and they're
going to [ __ ] in your mouth
and then he's going to lick your bottles
it's going to be messy it's going to be
rough
it reminds us of our discord ah
dude don't touch me don't
don't you already know
oh sounds exactly like the discord
you mastered someone comes yeah so
you're like talk dirty to me baby
yeah there's gonna be someone who's
gonna come out of the corner and [ __ ] in
your mouth
and then they're gonna play with your
bum how does this
get monetized but like have my videos
get demonetized for saying regular stuff
we just watched a girl kiss a hamster's
bum and talk about
mouse bar is demonetized for
minor for for minor stuff
i can't even say that word some minor
stuff
it's so hot in here or is it just me
do you have a boyfriend my boyfriend's
gonna be like what the hell did you just
say it
[Music]
even though she's all sloppy and goofy
he was like
it's my chance do you have a boyfriend
right now yeah yeah and he was like
[Music]
gotta get it in i had to say something
let the opponent
cut off your shirt yeah
just drink beer no it's not
just drink beers just don't count my
nipples right
here
[Music]
one oh oh yeah
[ __ ] let your opponent throw a pie in
your face i would gladly get pie in your
face
three two one pie
[Applause]
my dude oh sorry ah
that was a slip oh what's your
boyfriend's name
josh josh it's up to josh your
girlfriend here today got me
naked talking to me and sticky shut up
josh shut up
what it's going no i don't know bro i
actually don't mind this man
you got some confidence i mean i'm
rooting for my boy
let's go kenny get her
let the other team undress you down to
your underwear
[Laughter]
wow i'm shirtless right now
okay yeah let's do it all right josh i
can't look for this
dwight just do it all right what's that
[Music]
um hey man hey man hey man
i'm saying you miss 100
of the shots you don't take right
i'm good and he's shooting he said he
said what
who who's the center josh
i'm dunking anyways now
is that your outfit for raves
yes oh my gosh take a shot of fish sauce
i
love fish sauce you came to the wrong
person with this
do you like your slice sure it depends i
don't like drinking straight
what what what
what tell us i love fish sauce do you
love this sauce
oops you're asian
that's just how it went in my head god
if i knew it was gonna be this
easy i will just drove my car over here
you know
god damn it the last couple no one's
gonna want to ever play with me again
[Music]
yeah right that's right that's right
good game i'm late you did good for
someone in your safari underwear thank
you
we should hang out more what
money i mean it was interesting
what what people are willing to do for
200 dollars
kissing amsterdam
i get it some people adventurous and you
know it's like beer pong but like an
evolved version i would never play but
it's interesting stuff oh i'm happy for
uh
you know kenny he did his thing and and
he got his money so good for him
sorry josh did you get that
for two hundred dollars nah you gotta
add a couple of extra zeros
see on camera see recorded see
forever on the web
350 250 350
30 and you got me uh that's it for
today's video i don't know what the
point of this video was i just i popped
it in you never know how reaction's
gonna go sometimes it's insightful
sometimes it ain't we just kissing him
we don't know
[Music]
is